des réponses voilà ce qu'attend isabelle
fouillot en s'avançant dans lé tribunal
de vesoul ce vendredi l'occasion lui est
enfin donnée de s'adresser directement à
johnattan le face-à-face débute par le
visionnage d'une séquence celle des
nouveaux aveux de l'accusé qui craque
face à sa belle-mère en décembre 2018
échanges qui s'ensuit est poignant il
restera sans doute comme le moment fort
de ce procès tu te rends compte que tu
nous as pris alexia pourquoi oui j'ai
tout détruit je suis désolé pour tous
c'est si peu j'attends mieux johnattan
je ne peux rien dire de plus alors tant
pis je te souhaite un bon séjour en
prison
adieu je me résigne à pas savoir
vraiment ce qui s'est passé faut que je
fasse j'arrête de me torturer l'esprit
j'aurais pas la vérité maintenant mais à
qui passe les plus longtemps en prison
c'est tout ce que je demande s'appelle
fiona donc pas eu les réponses qu'elle
attendait mais pour la défense
johnatan a dit tout ce qu'il pouvait
l'adieu nhat hanh ce sont ces
explications elles sont cohérentes elle
s'explique au travers du profil de ce
garçon il ya des intervenants des
psychiatres hier qui se sont expliqués
le troisième psychiatre était très clair
on était parfaitement dans la
personnalité de johnatan laval vient
ensuite le témoignage de martine aubry
la maire de johnatan ampleur face aux
jurés elle dit aimer son fils et
s'excuse pour les mots difficiles
qu'elle a tenus à l'encontre de la
famille fouillot j'ai causé comme ça
avec mes manches pour moi c'était pas ne
serait pas mal
donc si je les ai blessé je me suis
excusé certes elle a voulu suivre son
fils mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
mots prononcés que les soirées après la
mort de d'alexis a été festif chez eux
c'est monstrueux dire une chose pareille
c'était important ça quand même que ce
matin le fasse son mea culpa par rapport
à ces termes là qu'ont été utilisée elle
à dire c'était important qu'elle le
fasse elle ne l'a pas fait spontanément
on a dû l'interroger sur ce point elle a
répondu
bon bah si c'est ça je m'excuse on va
s'en contenter de cette cinquième
journée on retiendra surtout la douleur
de deux mère meurtrie leur témoignage
pourrait compter à la veille du verdict